Jamie Authorities say this is now
a criminal investigation.
Several fires raging now down this street,
smashing grab flash mob at a Nordstrom
police, the number of homeless people on the streets
and in shelter, medical treatment for minors,
a surprise attack within Israel's borders.
People are for a
And an angel of the Lord appeared to them
and the glory of the Lord shown around them
and they were filled with fear.
And the angel said to them, fear not for behold.
I bring good news of great joy.
Well, is it too early to say Merry Christmas?
I, I don't think so, right? Is that okay?
Some stores have been saying it
for two months already, so I think we're okay.
Uh, but no, it is, uh, one of my favorite times
of year really is uh, not just
'cause our oldest son was born Christmas Eve, but
because it's just such a, a, a sense of excitement
and anticipation and lots of joy
and all the things that come with this celebration time.
That's really the essence of this short Christmas series.
We're gonna embark on this season a series
that we're calling Good News of great joy,
as you just saw in the bumper video there.
That's a phrase we borrowed from the angels on the
night Jesus was born.
Uh, but really it, it, it talks about a, a sense of
when we look around in the world, as you saw, like there's
so much chaos, so much that we can look at
and say, man, things are not good.
But there was,
and is still good news of great joy.
The reason it was such good news though,
the reason it would spark great joy at the time was
because of what they were waiting for back then of
what they were anticipating in their lives.
'cause Israel had been given promises for thousands
of years, promises that they trusted the Lord to fulfill
that he would come through for them.
But, but at that time, 2000 years ago for us, but,
but at that time, he hadn't really come through yet fully.
They were still waiting for so many things.
And then you add to that,
for the 400 years preceding Jesus' birth,
God had been silent.
There was nothing they had heard about any of those promises
or about anything that would give them hope.
And so to them it may have seemed like
that God had forgotten them
or maybe that God had abandoned them.
Well, what we're gonna see over the next four weeks
is four different responses to that announcement
of good news, of great joy.
How did four unique people in this whole
Christmas narrative scene,
how did they respond when they heard of this good news
of great joy, when they heard of
what Jesus' appearance was going to bring?
How did they respond to that? What did it mean to them?
And what we're gonna see, I think, is that this good news
can bring great joy even to us today.
And so we're gonna be in the gospel according to Luke
for the next couple weeks, just chapters one and two.
So go ahead and turn there with me, put a bookmark there
for the next few Sundays in the New Testament, Matthew,
mark, and then Luke.
And we're gonna bounce around those two chapters a little
bit, looking at these four characters and their responses.
But today we're gonna look at Mary, the mother of Jesus
and how she responded to all that she saw
and heard about this Messiah that was promised
that she'd heard about before,
but then some of the direct parts of what that looks like.
We're gonna see it in her response.
We'll be in Luke 1 46 through 55 to see that.
But we gotta get some context
before we get there of,
of helping us see why she would've responded.
The way that we'll see that she did,
I already said God had been silent for 400 years.
That means there was no prophet,
there was no vision from God about any
of these things in their life.
Nothing. And so all seemed lost at that point.
There were just a handful of people
still kind of hanging on.
Yet in this moment,
not only did God show up to Zechariah
and to his barren wife Elizabeth
and promised them a son, his name was John,
who was gonna be the forerunner of the Messiah.
We're actually gonna study zechariah's response next week.
But not only did God show up there to kind
of fulfill his promise at the end of the Old Testament,
he's showing up again here.
But in a similar way, an angel came to Mary
to tell her about a miraculous baby coming her way as well.
Yes, John was coming miraculously for them.
But here for Mary, a miraculous birth was coming.
And this, this is again background information going back up
to to chapter one verse 26.
This is the scene that sets this for Mary of
what was happening for her In the six month.
The angel Gabriel was sent from God to a city
of Galilee named Nazareth to a virgin betroth,
to a man whose name was Joseph of the house of David.
And the Virgin's name was Mary.
And the angel came to her
and said, greetings, oh favored one, the Lord is with you.
But she was greatly troubled at the saying
and tried to discern what sort of greeting this might be.
And the angel said to her, do not be afraid, Mary,
for you found favor with God
and behold, you'll conceive in your womb
and bear a son, you shall call his name Jesus.
He will be great. He will be called the
son of the most high.
And the Lord God will give to him the throne
of his father David.
And he will reign over the house
of Jacob forever and of his kingdom.
There will be no end.
And Mary said to the angel, how will this be
since I am a virgin?
And the angel answered her,
the Holy Spirit will come upon you
and the power of the most high will overshadow you.
Therefore, the child to be born will be called holy,
the son of God.
And behold, your relative, Elizabeth
and her old age has also conceived a son.
This is the sixth month with her who was called barren.
For nothing will be impossible with God.
And Mary said, behold, I am the servant of the Lord.
Let it be to me according to your word.
And the angel departed from her.
Now that's the setting here
where Mary had had this encounter with the angel.
He told her what was happening, what was about to happen,
all of the scenarios.
And, and so what we learned from
that is not only was was Mary informed
and she was, she was instructed about this,
we also learned some things about this whole process,
about this baby that was coming.
Notice first that this baby was the fulfillment of
so many prophecies from the Old Testament
and, and just a couple of those.
He was to be of the house of David.
Remember she was betrothed to Mary Joseph
and Joseph was of the house of David.
It says explicitly there.
And so this was prophesied all the way back in Jeremiah 23.
Isaiah 11, that this was, this Messiah was to be
of the house of David.
There you go. It also says here that he was the son of God,
the son of the most high.
Well that was predicted back in Psalm two, Hosea 11,
that this was going to be known as the son of God.
And so Mary understood by virtue of an angel coming
and her getting pregnant, right like that,
that was, that was miraculous.
This whole process was miraculous.
Like she, she'd never seen an angel before we think.
And so that was part of it.
But then like this angel tells her these things
that this is going to be the Lord.
That baby is not just a baby, it's the Lord.
She understood, even though she didn't understand the
mechanics of how all this was working out,
she understood that was happening.
But notice throughout this passage,
she trusted God, right?
If you have to go base level, bottom line, this is
what she shows us.
She trusted God.
That's why Mary responded with the way
that we'll see her respond in our main passage here in
verses 46 through 55.
See, she began to understand what was happening to her life
and look at her trust in the Lord.
Starting in verse 46, Mary said, my soul magnifies the Lord.
My spirit rejoices in God, my savior,
for he has looked on the humble estate of his servant.
For behold, from now on,
all generations will call me blessed, for he who is mighty,
has done great things for me.
And holy is his name.
And his mercy is for those
who fear him from generation to generation.
He has shown strength with his arm.
He scattered the proud and the thoughts of their hearts.
He's brought down the mighty from their thrones
and exalted those of humble estate.
He has filled the hungry with good things
and the rich, he sent away empty.
He has helped his servant Israel in remembrance of his mercy
as he spoke to our fathers, to Abraham,
to his offspring for her.
Isn't that beautiful? I mean, you just look at this.
I'm so thankful that God chose
to record Mary's testimony here, like her perspective on
what was happening in her life, what God was doing in her,
what God was doing in history, right?
He's, she's looking at this
and saying, here's what I see God doing.
And God said, here's what I want you for generations,
forever to know about me through Mary.
Thank you God for that. Right?
But as I began studying through this,
I was noticing some things that Mary said a lot about
how God flips stuff on its head,
like God doesn't work in the normal ways
that we think he would work it.
He tends to work differently.
That's how one commentator actually described
what Mary was saying here, where when you take
what she says, plus what Jesus ended up doing
for the 33 years he was here on Earth, like
how that all played out.
When you take all that together, the way they said it is
that God is the God of the upside down kingdom.
That's what we're learning from this, is that God is the God
of the upside down kingdom that he came,
Jesus took on flesh.
God the Son took on flesh, came to be with us in,
in some sense to reverse the world's power structures
that he doesn't work through.
The same means that we think we should.
And you see that throughout the passage, right?
A lowly person like Mary exalted,
the proud and the strong in the world scattered,
brought down from their thrones.
It says, the hungry
filled the rich emptied,
the tiny forgotten nation of Israel remembered
and helped in a
way you could say Jesus when he came, began a revolution.
Now, Mary kind of implies that as we read through this,
but Jesus himself,
just a couple chapters later in chapter four verses 18
and 19, he stands up in the synagogue
and he gives his mission statement.
Basically, this is what I came to do.
Just listen to this, Luke four 18
and 19, the spirit of the Lord is upon me.
He's quoting Isaiah 61.
The spirit of the Lord is upon me
because he has anointed me
to proclaim good news to the poor.
He has sent me to proclaim liberty to the captives
recovering of sight to the blind, to set at liberty those
who are oppressed, to proclaim the year of the Lord's favor.
Revolutionary language, right?
See, listen, we tend to make Christmas a, a, a season
of warm fuzzies, lights
and traditions, cookies and presents.
And I, I love all of those things.
We've, we've stripped Christmas down
to a manageable consumeristic holiday.
But what we need to learn here from Mary is
how revolutionary the birth of Christ really was.
I mean, just look at the language here, right?
Because remember, Jesus didn't come just to restore Israel
to its former glory.
He didn't come just to make the atmosphere better for them
and they could have a, a good time again like they used to.
He came to do something completely different.
He came to bring a whole new kingdom, a kingdom of love
that was not based in the world's power structures anymore.
In fact, it's based on something very different
and deeper and eternal.
It's founded on a personal relationship with God
through faith where your sins are now covered by his blood
and the spirit lives inside you.
Now, that's a whole new way of doing life.
Now. It's a new kingdom, it's a different world.
It's eternal, it's above. It's not the world's structures.
And as we saw throughout Colossians, what
that does then is it makes you different.
It makes us different.
It makes you new where you start to speak differently.
You love differently. You sing differently.
You work differently. You forgive differently.
Your marriage is different. Your parenting is different.
Your singleness is different.
Your friendships are different.
Because remember, the old has gone, the new has come
That inner transformation, new heart, new spirit,
new flesh gives you changed kingdom in the world,
gives you new life in the world,
gives you difference in the world.
That's what Jesus not to take over politically.
He came to take over hearts so that
that would change the world around them.
But that's what kinda illustrated by this is
what happens when this upside down
kingdom begins to break through.
Some things could be confusing to us at times.
Like we don't always understand what that looks like.
But here's one of the things that we can learn from Mary's
song, is that God is worthy of praise.
Even when nothing makes sense,
like it's confusing, doesn't make sense.
He is still worthy of praise.
And look again at how she started this song.
Verse 46 through 49, Mary said, my soul magnifies the Lord.
My spirit rejoices in God my savior.
He's looked on the humblest state of his servant.
From behold, from now on,
all generations will call me blessed, for he who is mighty,
has done great things for me.
And holy is his name.
This whole section is often referred to as the
magnifica may have heard that before.
It's typically said about this song in this way.
Why is it called that? Because
that's the first word in the Latin translation of this, that
as she's saying here, my soul magnifies the Lord.
That's a word that means to glorify, to exalt, to lift high
or, or you might think of a magnifying glass.
Kids, you've kids, you've used a magnifying glass
before where you've hold it up there
and you see something a lot closer.
You're focusing in on it, right?
That that's what this is doing.
She's saying, my goal is to focus people's attention
on the one who deserves it, to magnify,
make bigger in people's hearts the Lord, Yahweh.
And notice, again, Mary looked around at her circumstances
and even though none of it made sense,
even though she couldn't explain any of it,
she still praised the Lord.
She still said, God, you are worthy of it.
Now, this was not new for Mary, right?
She didn't just come up outta nowhere
and all of a sudden be able to express these truths and
and worship God like this.
She had been doing this her entire life.
She'd seen God as worthy. She loved him.
And verse 47 says, she rejoiced in God, her savior.
'cause remember she was looking for the Messiah too.
And God looked at her and said, you're favored.
You're blessed. Not so that we would worship her,
but that that we would see her as an example.
And what she began to realize
as she's considering all the things that she's known
and learned and heard her entire life,
and now the things that are happening right now,
what she's beginning to realize is that this baby
that she was carrying was that Savior the Messiah
that they were waiting for, that he was going
to be her deliverer like the song Mary did.
You know, yes she did.
Maybe not all the implications, but she knew this.
Look at what she's saying about the one that she's carrying.
She knew. So even though none
of Mary's circumstances made sense, she could look back at
what God had did throughout the ages.
She could look at what he was even
doing right at that moment.
She could see all those things.
And what she could do then is she could worship her.
God, is
that something that you can do?
Are you able to do the same thing
that she is exemplifying here?
That even, even when nothing in your life makes sense,
even when it all seems to be falling apart,
are you still able to magnify the Lord
and rejoice in the Lord your savior?
Are you able to do what she does?
And, and I know the stories in in part in this room,
you might not think right now
that you have anything in your life
that you could give thanks for.
Well, listen, if you have turned from
your sin and turned to Jesus in faith,
there's always something that you can give thanks for.
It's your salvation is secure in him, right?
Even if everything's falling apart around you,
even you have nothing else, you have a savior.
And you can rejoice in God, your savior,
because that's right.
What this is is good news of great joy, right?
We're not talking good news of great happiness
because that's circumstantial
and that can be taken away as soon as you lose
that Nintendo that you just got, right?
Like that can be, that can be taken away.
But joy is eternal.
And so you have the ability to have this constant eternal
look at things no matter what it is, which means God.
There's always something to give praise to you
for even when nothing makes sense.
He is worthy of our praise.
But there's also another part
of this upside down kingdom that we learn from.
Mary's song here is that he humbles the proud
who don't trust in him.
Remember, God is turning things on its head
and the way that things work here, he humbles the proud
who don't trust in him.
And you see that throughout this passage.
Look again, at verses 51 through 53, he has shown
strength with his arm.
He's scattered the proud in the thoughts of their hearts.
He's brought down the mighty from their thrones.
He's exalted those of humble estate filled the hungry
with good things, but the rich he has sent away empty.
Like how revolutionary is that? Right?
This is how upside down the kingdom really is.
In fact, this section of scripture has been banned
by communist countries throughout history.
It has been said to missionaries in hard places, don't read
that you're already inflammatory enough by your presence.
Don't read that section. This is a
revolutionary idea of what God came to do.
This is what Jesus does. He reverses all human values.
What the world esteems, what the world values
and holds high, he turns it on its head.
'cause again, remember that Rome was in charge at the
time this was written.
They were often oppressing the Jews.
Even religious leadership was full
of selfish pride at the time.
And so for Mary to say
that Jesus was gonna do things like scatter the proud,
bring down those on their thrones, send the rich away empty.
You see how revolutionary that was us Like there.
He's poking the bear here, right?
But again, that's what God does.
He humbles the proud,
because in essence, when you're prideful,
that means you don't trust God.
You trust yourself. That's the definition of pride, right?
I know that's been true in my life, that I
so often have thought that I have enough
to accomplish whatever task is in front of me.
I've pridefully thought
that I could handle whatever is coming my way.
Whatever is right there, I'm, I could handle this.
I could be good enough. Listen, I even thought this
for 20 some years of my, my life,
like I could be good enough for God to save me.
I may never have said that to anybody,
but that's the way I functioned, that I, I,
I could be decent enough of a person
that surely God would save me, right?
Or, or even that, that I, I'm, I'm talented enough
to make some things happen.
I can, I can create this.
I could, I could be skilled enough to do big things even
for God, like in the, I could be skilled enough
to make things happen for the Lord, right?
That's all just pride. Because here's the reality.
First of all, that forgets
that God gave me everything to begin with.
Even the abilities you have, even the mind you have,
even the, the situation you were brought up
in God gave you that.
So what right? Do you have to boast about any of that?
But also you heard it throughout that whole thing.
It it's also just saying to God, I don't need you.
I've got this.
And listen, if that's at the core of
who you are, then beware.
Now I know 'cause I did it for a long time.
I know you can cover it with some spiritual language, right?
You can. You can not let that get out too publicly too much.
Like nobody's ever gonna think that nobody, no,
I'm never gonna say, and you can cover it,
but what are your motivations?
What? What are the things that are deep in the
core of who you are?
That's, that's prideful. That's where you need to be. Where?
Because God humbles the proud.
Those who don't trust in him, God humbles.
And so that's a warning. But also, see in the context of
what Mary's saying this, think of the hope that
that would've brought the Israelites in that moment, right?
They're they're oppressed, they're cast off.
They're pushed to the side.
Mary stands up and says, Hey, actually this is
what the Messiah's coming to do.
And they would've been like, yes, There's hope.
Because not only does God humble,
the proud in this upside down kingdom, he also
exalts the humble who do trust in him.
He will humble the proud who don't trust in him.
But he also in the same move, exalts, the humble
who do trust in him, who are waiting for him,
who are looking to him
like just remember it was in the first section, the context.
Remember how Mary responded
to the angel when he told her what was about to happen?
This is back up in verse 38.
Mary said, behold, I am the servant of the Lord.
Let it be to me, according to your word,
that word servant is the same word, often translated slave.
And she says it again here in verse 48 in our section,
that God has looked on the humble estate
of his servant, right?
You see the humility here?
You see this submission to the Lord here,
that she just comes to him
and says, okay, God, I'm your slave.
You are the eternal king. You're the eternal savior.
And so I am giving you, you are worthy of my whole life.
And so you see her humility,
but also you see her trust in God.
She could legitimately say to this, God, let it be
to me according to your word.
In other words, whatever you want,
God, I'm yours.
This is yours. All of life is yours.
And listen, that's one of the most beautiful aspects
of this whole passage today.
When you think about who she is, think about the context
that God is bringing salvation
through her in a sense, right?
Like he's bringing his savior through her body.
Like this is amazing to think about when you think about
how this works out.
The beautiful passage of this is that you don't have
to be mighty for God to use you.
And just look at who he's using here.
He's using an unwed pregnant teenage girl.
Remember that could have gotten her stoned
killed in that context.
And yet God said, I'm gonna use this.
You don't have to be mighty.
You don't have to be in the perfect situation.
You can be humble
because look, again, verse 49, he who is
mighty has done great things for me.
She says that she's about to deliver Jesus.
He who's mighty has done great things for me.
In other words, she's saying it's all God.
I brought nothing to the table here. This is all God.
You don't have to be strong. Hear me on this.
You don't have to bring all this strength.
It's just what Paul wrote,
one Corinthians one, and here's why.
You don't have to bring strength to the table
for consider your calling.
Brothers, not many of you were wise according
to worldly standards.
Not many were powerful. Not many were of noble birth.
But God chose what is foolish in the
world to shame the wise.
God chose what is weak in the world to shame the strong
God chose what is low despised in the world, even things
that are not to bring to nothing, things
that are upside down, right?
So that here's why. So
that no human being might boast in the presence
of God because of him.
You're in Christ Jesus who became to us wisdom from God,
righteousness, sanctification, redemption,
all the things you desperately need.
God did it so that as it is written, let the one
who boasts boast in the Lord.
Why does God choose to use the weak?
Why does God choose to use the un?
Why does he use the messes that we are? Why did he use Mary?
Because that's how he gets the most glory.
That's how he shows off.
So you don't have to be strong, you don't have to be mighty.
You don't have to have it all together. No, you need to,
as Luke one 50 says, you need to fear him
because his mercy is for those who fear him.
What does it mean to fear God? It means to revere him.
It means you don't trust yourself. You trust him.
That's what it means to fear God.
Because in the upside down kingdom of God,
the way down is actually the way up.
You get that He exalts those who humble themselves.
He lifts up those who humble themselves.
The way up is actually first the way down.
That's how you're exalted. That's how you're blessed.
That's how you're filled with good things
that he says here through His word.
As verse 53 says, you're hungry for him.
You're not going to humble yourself
before him if you're not hungry for him,
if you don't actually want him.
But when you are, when you do hunger
for him, you long for him.
You're looking for him to work.
He fills you just like those faithful few were doing
back in Mary's day.
They were looking, waiting, longing for this God to come.
He exalts the humble.
But there's one final way that this song
of Mary illustrates this upside down kingdom.
It's in verses 55 and 54
and 55 here at the end of this passage
especially says he has helped his servant Israel in
remembrance of his mercy as he spoke to our fathers,
to Abraham and to his offspring forever.
Again. Remember at this time, all hope seemed lost.
God had been silent for four centuries. Rome had taken over.
Israel didn't really have their land
that they'd been promised, and all this seemed
to be out of control.
Yet in Mary's mind,
because of all of this,
the revolution had started This thing's coming.
She looked around the circumstances.
She had this miraculous baby in her womb.
She had John and Elizabeth's womb.
She knew of that of what they were hearing from the angels.
She put all this together,
and even though it sure seemed like all was lost,
Mary trusted that God actually does keep his promises.
That's what she's seeing. It seemed like hope was lost.
But she looked back and she said, oh, no, actually
God does keep his promises.
That's what she's talking about with this quote.
It's actually from Genesis 12, two.
She's referencing that where God promised Abraham,
the father of Israel, this back in Genesis 12, two,
I will make of you a great nation.
I will bless you. Make your name great so
that you will be a blessing.
God reiterated that promise over
and over throughout the generations of Israel
that he was going to mercifully deliver his people
and then use them for his glory among the nations.
He would send a redeemer to deliver them,
to save them, to help them.
He was going to do it and then use them.
Well, Mary says, Hey, that Tom finally arrived.
Here it is. All the stuff we've been waiting for.
Here it is. God remembered his mercy.
He remembered his love that would relieve suffering.
He remembered the way that he was going to help us.
How is he gonna help us by sending his son in the flesh?
See, when we read this, we know
and we tie it all with the Old Testament,
that Jesus Christ is the fulfillment of all
of those promises.
The promise to Abraham, the promise to Jacob, to Moses,
to Joshua, to David, all of those promises.
Jesus is God's mercy.
And it says here, his mercy is for those who fear him
from generation to generation back then, same way,
but even today to those who fear him,
his mercy comes.
And so here's the reality of this.
God still humbles the proud who don't trust in him.
His strength will still scatter.
Those who turn their backs on him,
his judgment will come on those
who stiffen their neck against God.
And I know that some of you in this room fall into
that category where there's a, a measure
of, of, yeah, you've lived a decent life.
You, you might even be a church member.
You might be better than the jerk down the street
who you know, man, he's way far from God.
But I'm not, listen, if
if your heart inside of you is still opposed
to God, if you've turned your back on God, I said,
no, I'm doing it my way.
I'm gonna give you a little bit here and there,
but I'm not gonna give you anything
that's really gonna count
or cost me anything if I'm not gonna submit my life to him.
Listen, it doesn't matter.
All those other things that you do, it's not enough.
You can do as much as you want.
It's not enough to
overcome your rebellion in your heart towards a holy God.
And so you ought to fear God.
Fear his strong arm, fear his judgment.
But notice his mercy is for those who fear him
and and so, so yes, he humbles those who exalt themselves,
but, but he elevates exalts, those
who humble themselves, who, who look at his life, death
and resurrection in their place and say, God, I am yours.
I need that. I can't do anything myself.
I need you to do it for me. He lifts those up.
That's salvation. And if you're hungry for him,
he'll fill you with those good things like love and joy
and peace and patience, all of the fruit of the spirit.
He's gonna fill you with that. That's what he does.
To exalt the humble, to lift up those who trust him,
who say, God, you are my Lord, my savior.
I'm all in. He exalts and lifts up.
See, listen, you might think,
and you've been in church maybe here and there,
and you've kind of known some of these truths
and you kind of like Christmas and Easter,
but you don't really know if you're in on this stuff.
But then at the same time, you're exhausted
because you've been trying so hard to make it work yourself.
You might get to a place where you think like all is lost,
that I've gone too far.
I can never be loved like that.
You saw it before. Nothing is impossible with God.
Even the salvation of you
and you think you're the worst sinner ever.
Nothing is impossible with God.
He will lift up those who trust in him.
If you turn from your sin
and you turn to Jesus in faith, you are safe forever.
But I also wanna talk to you believer
that I think this speaks to us in a way that we look
around at our lives, can look at life,
and it feels like everything's fallen apart,
that the darkness is winning it.
It can feel like there's no hope
for your situation to get any better.
It's just the way it's gonna be.
Remember first, this God is worthy of your praise.
Even when nothing makes sense,
even when it seems like it's all fallen apart,
he's still worthy of praise.
But also, remember this, the last thing
that she said in her song, God does keep his promises
even when all seems lost,
even when it seems like death is winning and death is all.
You know, even when there's seemingly no light at the end
of the tunnel, he keeps his promises
because he's the God of the upside down kingdom here.
He doesn't work according to our ways.
He doesn't work according to our timelines,
But here's what we do.
No, he's not concerned primarily with our comfort.
He's primarily concerned with our holiness.
So he's gonna work it all out.
As Romans eight says, for the good of those who love him
and are called according to his purpose,
you can trust him in that,
that he is actually working in all of the chaos
and darkness for something good.
If you love him, it takes trust, right?
That doesn't automatically happen. It takes trust.
Mary looked at her life, looked at her history,
looked at her people's history, and said, okay, God's good.
I'm gonna trust him. And he fulfilled his promises.
Here's what you need to say.
You need to say with Mary that you are
the servant of the Lord.
And your desire above all else is for the will of God
to be done in your life.
That's it. God, I don't,
I don't know what else you're gonna do.
I dunno how this all gonna work out,
but God, my desire is for you to be magnified
through my life, even if it means I suffer,
even if it means it hurts a little bit.
I know you deserve the glory, not me.
So I'm gonna trust you with it, And I'm gonna trust you
that one day it's all gonna work out.
Even if that means nothing in this life ever works out one
day, it's going to when Jesus returns
and all things are made right again.
And I trust you with that God.
And even if you think right now
that you're too insignificant, how could God ever use me?
How could God ever want to use somebody like me?
Listen, that's the kind of person God loves to use
for his glory, to advance his kingdom.
So don't feel like you can't be used what he wants to use
as someone who is devoted to him.
May it be so of us church individually
and all of us together devoted to this Lord.